[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend schabbat schalom als heute
abend die sonne untergehen begann für
die juden in deutschland
der sabbat zwischen yom kippur und dem
laubhüttenfest eine schöne zeit an sich
dieses jahr ist es vor allem der sabbat
nach dem terror von handel menschen im
ganzen land vorabend vor allem aber in
halle an der saale versuchen ihren
jüdischen mitbürgern heute zu zeigen
ihr seid nicht allein aufrichtige
anträge tiefe trauer
zwei tage nach dem anschlag von halle
ist das was die stadt auch heute wieder
zusammenbringt so einer kleinstadt wie
halle hat man das eigentlich nie für
möglich gehalten
man kann es immer nur aus münchen berlin
da es nun schon sehr mitgenommen
ich bin einfach nur traurig und möchte
mein respekt und trauer zeigen
den ganzen tag über gibt es
gedenkveranstaltungen
wie hier bei der schabbat feier vor der
synagoge dem ort in dem stefan b
versucht hatte ein massaker unter
jüdischen gläubigen anzurichten
schabbat der siebte tag der woche heute
in halle 1 versuche normalität
zurückzuholen
aber dieser rabatt ist anders die wunde
noch sichtbar
max privat ski der vorsitzende der
jüdischen gemeinde in halle nimmt uns
mit zeigt uns die spuren der gräueltat
also die granate wahrscheinlich war nie
so große wechselbank auch wenn zum
zeitpunkt des attentats kein
sicherheitspersonal vor der synagoge
stand von innen wurde der eingang über
einen bildschirm bewacht während stefan
b versucht hatte in die synagoge
einzudringen musste max priwo roski mit
anderen gläubigen live mit ansehen was
draußen passiert
sie war böse bildungsmonitor wo wir
alles gesehen haben wir geschossen und
habt also eine smarte das war furchtbar
und nicht ob das gefühl von sicherheit
geborgenheit das gefühl von zuhause für
max privat ski wieder zurückkehren wird
im moment kann er sich das nur schwer
vorstellen
vielmehr spielt der vorsitzende der
jüdischen gemeinde in halle mit dem
gedanken deutschland zu verlassen
also ich kann nur über mich sprechen ich
bin so nicht nicht jetzt aber soll wie
geplant im hps und komme ich ein
hoffnungsschimmer
die große solidarität die ihm von allen
seiten und auf allen ligen erreicht
unzählige e mails also so viele leute
also dass das hat mich wirklich
möglicherweise das wir beitragen dass
sich wiederwählen
wie viel zu hause führen
[Musik]
zusammenhalt eine hoffnung auf das
gefühl von heimat innenminister horst
seehofer forderte heute in was nun im
zdf als lehre aus dem schreckenstag von
halle erweiterte möglichkeiten für die
polizei und den verfassungsschutz
ich habe heute stundenlang mit dem
bundeskriminalamt und dem bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz gesprochen
diese person dieser täter ist den
sicherheitsbehörden nicht aufgefallen
dieses manifest das ins internet
gestellt worden ist so habe ich heute
erfahren ist am tag der tat in das
internet gestellt wurden
deshalb brauchen wir dringend in
deutschland die befugnisse für die
sicherheitsbehörden so wie wir es im
analogen bereich haben telefon zu
überwachen und ähnliches dass wir auch
das internet überwachen
es ist schwierig das komplette interview
mit horst seehofer finden sie natürlich
auf heute.de bleiben wir bei deutscher
politik die junge union trifft sich im
saarland und tut was die vorsitzende
kramp karrenbauer von ihr verlangt hat
die j
mischt sich ein nicht nur in der sache
auch in personalfragen und da ist der
favorit der parteijugend für die
kanzlerkandidatur ganz offensichtlich
jemand anderes als die vorsitzende und
das tut man auch laut und mathis
feldhoff berichtete aus kabul
es ist ein akt der solidarität
kranzniederlegung im gedenken an die
opfer von halle gleich zu beginn ihres
deutschlandtages will die otto führung
in begleitung ihres heutigen gastes
klarmachen dass für antisemitismus
keinen platz in der gesellschaft sein
doch eigentlich sind die 1000 dollar
nach saarbrücken gekommen um ihn zu
feiern
friedrich merz der er ist der heimliche
star nicht nur der jungen
christdemokraten die heimliche hoffnung
dass irgendjemand den karren aus dem
dreck zieht
jetzt kommt es darauf an auch wieder das
vertrauen in der bevölkerung zurück zu
holen
und da ist einiges aufzuarbeiten da
fehlt einiges solange die union nicht
gerne klare sprache position und
überzeugung vertritt wird sie nicht
wieder nach vorne kommen
gebt euch noch etwas auf mahnt der
vorsitzende den jubelnden saal und
friedrich merz ist der hype nur
scheinbar peinlich wenn kennt weiß dass
er es genießt vor einem halben jahr
hatte die vorsitzende noch den druck von
der yahoo eingefordert der heute zu
schaffen macht damals war die hoffnung
dass mit ihr die cdu wieder sichtbar
wird ich wünsche mir als cdu-vorsitzende
eine junge union die uns dampf macht die
uns druck macht und das ist etwas was
diese cdu-vorsitzender auch gut
aushalten kann
doch die hoffnung wurde enttäuscht
vielen j land fehlt cdu pur offen sagt
es kaum einer aber auf dem kongress in
der heimat von annegret kramp
karrenbauer bläst die eigene jugend
jetzt zur attacke in zwei anträgen wird
die urwahl der kanzlerkandidaten
gefordert und jeder weiß dass damit ak 1
fragen gestellt werden soll
ich glaube dass das auch unsere partei
eine ganz neue ganz neuen schwung
bringen könnte weil sie einfach auch
klar dass egal nach außen geht dass
mitbestimmung auch in den parteien
möglich ist ich finde ak hat eigentlich
ganz gut reagiert auf diese debatte in
dem sie gesagt hat sie braucht
eigentlich kein abstimmungsverfahren zu
fürchten
und dennoch erwarten nicht wenige dass
er sich erneut der abstimmung um die
macht stellt doch friedrich merz weiss
natürlich dass es unklug wäre ambitionen
überhaupt nur anzudeuten schließlich ist
er nicht der einzig denkbare kandidat
ministerpräsident armin laschet und
gesundheitsminister sparen stehen schon
in der kulisse
sie treten morgen auf und es war auch
klar dass annegret kramp karrenbauer als
neue parteivorsitzende ja auch fehler
macht
liebe freundinnen und freunde ich hätte
auch fehler gemacht und ich habe auch
wirklich fester und tiefer überzeugung
angriff kam karrenbauer zugesagt ihr bei
dieser schwierigen aufgabe die sie
angenommen hat am 17 dezember 2018 in
hamburg zu helfen und sie zu
unterstützen und zu dieser zusage stehe
ich es ist ein schaulaufen der
kandidaten dass die jlu in saarbrücken
veranstaltet dass sie die eigene
vorsitzende die erst am sonntag kommt
damit in frage stellen neben die
jungpolitiker ganz bewusst in kauf da
wir gerade bei der hohen kunst der
politik sind wo man gleichzeitig lächeln
und am stuhl sägen kann reden und nichts
sagen und unlösbare konflikte in luft
auflösen
heiße luft natürlich das bringt uns nun
zum unlösbaren drexhage streit da tut
sich plötzlich was was gestern noch
unmöglich schien ein schritt richtung
auflösung problem wenn einer aus der eu
austritt muss eine grenze her
auch in dieser ecke europas das ist
schwierig denn eine grenze die die
irische insel durchschneidet ist
unzumutbar für die katholische republik
irland
die katholiken in nordirland und eine
grenze die durch die irische see geht
kann großbritannien nicht akzeptieren
und die protestanten in nordirland schon
gar nicht also wohin damit
das schien unlösbar rund doch anna heißt
es jetzt in brüssel london und dublin es
könnte eine lösung geben wie das denn
also als erstes mal haben die briten das
kind umbenannt die
hoch vergifteten hochbelasteten begriffe
des bags stop und der zollunion tauchen
in den letzten 48 stunden hier überhaupt
nicht mehr auf die sind einfach weg
jetzt wird gesprochen von einer zoll
partnerschaft was das genau sein soll
eine tolle partnerschaft für nordirland
was das genau sein soll
da blieben die briten erst mal noch
details schuldig auch das schafft erst
mal verhandlungsspielräume aber ich will
damit nicht sagen dass die bewegung des
heutigen tages tatsächlich nur auf
wortspielen beruht tatsächlich hat boris
johnson sich in einer ganz
entscheidenden frage nämlich der frage
der irischen grenze bewegt bei einem
treffen mit dem irischen premierminister
gestern hat er zugesagt dass er
verstanden habe dass es keine zoll oder
sonst wie geartete grenze auf der insel
geben könne und hat eben deshalb diese
zoll partnerschaft ins spiel gebracht
die nordirland ganz nah eng am
binnenmarkt anbinden würde und dadurch
zoll und grenzkontrollen unnötig machen
würde
das hat sofort die kritiker der
nordirischen dioki auf den plan gerufen
die wollen dass nordirland ganz eng
angedockt an dem rest des königreiches
bleibt und deshalb wollen beide seiten
jetzt in einen verhandlungs tunnel oder
in einen verhandlungsmarathon einsteigen
hinter verschlossenen türen möglichst
wenig details raus lassen die dann
gleich wieder in verhandlungen aus den
verhandlungen zerschossen werden würden
und ausloten ob es tatsächlich in den
nächsten fünf tagen bis zum herbst
eu-gipfel am donnerstag irgendetwas
geben könnte einen text der den namen
austritts abkommen verdient hier in
brüssel gibt es viele skeptische
gesichter aber auch welche die von
hoffnungen durchdrungen sind
ich schaue vorläufig in ratlose
gesichter aber irgendwas scheint sich zu
bewegen
danke schön an und hier geht es weiter
mit nachrichten von gundula gause im
handelskonflikt zwischen den usa und
china wecken neue gespräche in
washington
vorsichtig hoffnungen auf eine
entspannung us-präsident trump hat mit
dem chinesischen
vize-ministerpräsidenten juli in der
vergangenen stunde offenbar eine teil
einigung erzielt china hat sich unter
anderem bereit erklärt in größerem
rahmen us
agrarprodukte zu importieren im gegenzug
verzichtet washington auf die für
kommende woche angekündigten zoll
erhöhungen heißt es soeben aus
washington
im konflikt mit dem iran schicken die
usa weitere soldaten nach saudi arabien
außerdem sollen zwei patriot
flugabwehrraketen systeme und kampfjet
geschwader in die region verlegt werden
erklärte us-verteidigungsminister es bei
insgesamt seien dann 3000 us soldaten
dort hintergrund sind luftangriffe auf
saudi arabische ölanlagen die usa machen
den iran dafür verantwortlich was
teheran zurückweist
zu den angriffen hatten sich schiitische
houthi rebellen aus dem jemen bekannt
die vom iran unterstützt werden
aufgrund einer belastung mit bakterien
haben deutsche molkerei unternehmen
einen groß angelegten rückruf gestartet
die erreger in der betroffenen milch
können gesundheitliche probleme wie
durchfall auslösen
sie seien über eine defekte dichtung in
einem werk im nordrhein westfälischen
everswinkel in die milch gelangt
betroffen seien nur ein liter packungen
frischer fettarmer milch dieser marken
die packungen haben die kennung d en
w508 eg und ein mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum
zwischen dem zehnten und zwanzigster
oktober in sachsen wollen cdu und spd
koalitionsverhandlungen mit den grünen
zur bildung einer gemeinsamen regierung
aufnehmen
ein solches sogenanntes kenia bündnis
gibt es bisher nur in sachsen anhalt die
sächsische cdu war bei der landtagswahl
anfang september stärkste kraft vor der
afg geworden
der bundesrat hat einen gesetzesentwurf
für ein rauchverbot im auto beschlossen
wenn schwangere oder kinder mit im
fahrzeug sitzen drohen bei verstößen
demnach geldstrafen zwischen 500 und
3000 euro
das rauchverbot soll wie beim handy
verbot durch verkehrskontrollen
überwacht werden die initiative war von
mehreren bundesländern ausgegangen
jetzt muss sich der bundestag mit dem
entwurf befassen
norwegens nobelkomitee hat den
friedensnobelpreis heute an
ein lichtblick in afrika vergeben ahmed
den mann der sein land und die region in
atemberaubenden tempo umkrempelt es ist
erst 18 monate her dass er überraschend
ministerpräsident von äthiopien wurde
ein land das geprägt war von krieg
unterdrückung und korruption
er war ein fast unbeschriebenes blatt
ein ehemaliger geheimdienstmann und
minister ist seine gegner märkten mit
wem sie es jetzt zu tun haben hatte der
schon den krieg mit eritrea beendet
tausende politische gefangene
freigelassen und pressefreiheit
etabliert das alles klingt nun schon
fast zu schön um wahr zu sein und der
mann ist auch keiner ohne fehl und tadel
aber das nobel- komitee war bereit den
preis wieder mal an eine hoffnung zu
geben
zehn jahre nach obama dem krüger
berichtet aus ostafrika lichtgestalt und
hoffnungsträger wird der genannte
äthiopien premierminister ahmed hat
trotz seines jungen alters schon eine
beträchtliche flughöhe erreicht seit
heute ist er zudem
friedensnobelpreisträger weil er schon
kurz nach seinem amtsantritt im
vergangenen jahr offiziell frieden
schloss mit erzfeind eritrea die mauer
die zwischen unseren völkern in den
vergangenen 20 jahren gegen ihren willen
aufgebaut wurde muss zerstört werden am
11 september 2018 dann unglaubliche
szenen am grenzübergang salloum basar
zwischen äthiopien und eritrea als die
grenze geöffnet wurde
mittlerweile sind die direkten
grenzübergänge wieder zu aber der
vernichtende grenzkrieg bei dem rund
80.000 menschen ums leben kamen und der
die region jahre lang in atem hielt ist
offiziell beendet
wenn die kopien und eritrea getrennt
sind sehen sie aus wie zwei unschöne
ornamente aber wenn sie zusammenhalten
sind sie das juwel des horns von afrika
des ganzen kontinents in der hauptstadt
addis abeba heute viel zustimmung
als ich die nachricht vom prius
nobelpreis hörte weise glücklich
äthiopien war bekannt für krieg und
dürren jetzt dabei richten sich die
augen wegen des nobelpreises auf uns ich
bin stolz äthiopien zu sein
verwundert rieben sich beobachter die
augen als abi auch noch in
atemberaubendem tempo demokratische
reformen durchführte eröffnete
gefängnisse die heute von der
öffentlichkeit besucht werden können
inhaftierte journalisten und aktivisten
kamen frei dabei war er selbst teil des
früheren repressiven staatsapparat in
die kopien
längst aber herrscht ernüchterung sein
reformkurs hat den politischen raum
geöffnet das aber hat zu massiven
ethnischen spannungen machtkämpfen und
gewalt geführt regionen wollen sich
abspalten hunderttausende sind auf der
flucht
im sommer vergangenen jahres bereits gab
es einen anschlag während einer von
abbys kundgebungen im juni dieses jahres
dann kam es zu einem regionalen
putschversuch bei dem der
generalstabschef der nationalen armee
getötet wurde
ob barbie den 100 millionen
vielvölkerstaat äthiopien zusammenhalten
kann ist ungewiss sagen experten
sein komplize es gibt derzeit viele
ethnische und religiöse konflikte viele
menschen sind deswegen gestorben
die menschenrechtsverletzungen haben
noch nicht aufgehört aber sie sind
zumindest weniger geworden jetzt tobt
ist immerhin der friede mit eritrea hat
hoffnungen auf eine bessere zukunft am
ganzen horn von afrika geweckt auch
barbie in der region als vermittler
auftritt als denkendes vertrag und die
wiederannäherung zwischen eritrea und
äthiopien waren nur der anfang
das hat sich auf den sudan ägypten
dschibuti und somalia ausgeweitet so
maly unterstützung für abi kommt auch
aus deutschland
im kommenden jahr sollen in äthiopien
freie wahlen stattfinden der
friedensnobelpreis für abu ahmed ist
eine auszeichnung vor allem aber auch
auftrag den schwierigen weg
weiterzugehen vom friedensnobelpreis
leider zum akuten kriegsgeschehen an der
nordsyrischen grenze wo der vormarsch
der türkischen armee vorangeht sie soll
eine 30 kilometer zone entlang der
grenze schaffen in der erdogan angeblich
syrische flüchtlinge zwangs ansiedeln
will
die kurdischen truppen nutzen ihre
artillerie auch auf türkische grenzorte
fliegen granaten und treffen die
türkische zivilbevölkerung appelle an
erdogan aus aller welt diese aktion zu
stoppen verpuffen wirkungslos
die reporterin berichtet live aus
kamishli der syrisch kurdischen stadt an
der grenze als die granate explodiert
panik tote verletzte
am dritten tag der offensive
bombardierte die türkische armee heute
wieder auf mehr als 100 kilometern länge
ziele in nordsyrien chaos tote und
verletzte auch bei diesem granat
einschlag diesmal im türkischen
nusseibeh gleich gegenüber von
chemischen auch hier leben vor allem
kurden wer das geschoss von der anderen
seite abfeuerte unklar
klar aber ist die militäroffensive der
türkei sie kostet menschenleben
auch im eigenen land eu-ratspräsident
tusk erneuerte heute noch einmal die
kritik der europäer
die einseitige militäroperationen der
türkei in syrien ist äußerst
besorgniserregend und sollte beendet
werden
das sind die neuen herren in der von der
türkei geplanten sogenannten schutzzone
arabische freischärler die mit der
unterstützung der türkischen armee
bislang neun dörfer von den kurdischen
milizen erobert haben
sie stoßen weiter vor angegriffen wurden
dabei auch wasserversorgungssysteme und
kraftwerke den bewohnern bleibt nur die
flucht die einst von kämpfen verschonte
region ist in auflösung begriffen
wir müssen weg die kinder werden
beschossen sie sterben und niemand hilft
nach un angaben sind inzwischen 100.000
menschen auf der flucht und die zahl
wird weiter steigen
sie fliehen vor allem ins landesinnere
ins 100 kilometer südlich gelegene arag
die behörden dort richten gerade vier
große notunterkünfte ein und wir
versuchen lebensmittel dahin zu schaffen
in washington versucht sich die
regierung derweil in schadensbegrenzung
der finanzminister kündigte die
ausarbeitung von sanktionen gegen die
türkei an
das ist sehr scharfe sanktionen wir
hoffen dass wir sie nicht brauchen aber
notfalls werden die türkische wirtschaft
lahm
präsident erdogan ficht das nicht an
auch die warnungen von
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg im
hinblick auf tausende im kampfgebiet
immer vierte es terroristen ließ er mit
einem kalten händedruck links liegen
wir werden unsere operationen gegen die
kurdischen terror kräfte der gpg nicht
stoppen
egal was die anderen dazu sagen der
himmel über akku leer war auch heute
abend wieder erfüllt vom feuer der
kanonen und dem lärm der explosion
zurück nach deutschland und zu
nachrichten aus der wird der autobauer
daimler muss erneut hunderttausende
diesel fahrzeuge zurückrufen
das stuttgarter unternehmen hat nach
ansicht des kraftfahrt-bundesamtes in
weiteren dieselfahrzeugen eine
unzulässige abgastechnik verwendet
darunter ältere euro 5 diesel und das
vorgängermodell des aktuellen sprinters
daimler will mit den behörden
kooperieren und kündigte zugleich aber
auch in diesem fall widerspruch an
an der börse hat europas größter it
konzern sap schlagzeilen gemacht
überraschend hat vorstand bill mcdermott
seinen rückzug erklärt eine jüngere
doppelspitze übernimmt der deutsche
christian klein und die amerikanerin
jennifer morgen stefanie bareth sie ist
damit die erste frau an der spitze eines
dax konzerns sap
schreibt doch damit geschichte ja
wirklich ein historischer tag in der
deutschen wirtschaftsgeschichte denn dem
baden-württembergischen softwarekonzern
ist heute sogar eine doppelte premiere
gelungen neben der ersten frau an der
spitze des dax konzerns wird nämlich der
deutsche christian klein mit 39 jahren
jüngster vorstandsvorsitzender
das führungsduo wird künftig gemeinsam
die geschicke des walldorfer
unternehmens lenken
jennifer morgen hat maßgeblich die
transformation sap es von der reinen
software entwicklung hin zum
gewinnbringenden cloud computing dh der
vermietung von software und dem
datenspeichern auf externen rechen
netzwerken gemanagt der bisherige chef
bill mcdermott führte den walldorfer
softwarekonzern an die weltspitze und
machte sap zum wertvollsten konzern im
dax noch vor siemens und vw
doch die zukunft birgt auch haus
herausforderungen der wettbewerb wird
schärfer
das lukrative cloud business haben
nämlich auch andere firmen für sich
entdeckt die börse traut dem neuen
führungsduo aber viel zu die aktie
gewann satte zehn prozent dazu und
verliert im dax insgesamt rückenwind der
gewand zum wochenschluss sage und
schreibe 347 punkte dazu für optimismus
an der börse hier sorgte nicht nur die
meldung dass sich eu und großbritannien
anscheinend näher kommen auch die
entspannung am us chinesischen
handelsstreit ließ die anleger beflügelt
ins wochenende gehen
dann schauen wir auf montag was dann an
der börse passiert vielen dank steffi
hinsehen der us sportartikelhersteller
nike hat das umstrittene laufteam morgen
projekt beendet kurz nach der sperrung
von cheftrainer sasa der gründungsvater
dieses trainingsprogramms soll gegen
anti doping regeln verstoßen haben
nike weist alle doping vorwürfe zurück
sieht aber die athleten beeinträchtigt
auf die deutsche langstreckenläuferin
constanze klosterhalfen ist betroffen
und muss sich ein neues trainingscamp
suchen zum vogel des jahres 2020 ist die
turteltauben gewählt worden
naturschützer wollen so auf die starke
bedrohung des lebensraums der vogelart
und den enormen rückgang hier bei uns in
deutschland aufmerksam machen
seit 1980 seien fast 90 prozent der
heimischen bestände verloren gegangen so
brüteten hierzulande weniger als 22.000
turteltauben paare vor allem ausweitung
und art der landwirtschaft bedrohten
nistplätze sowie nahrungs und trinkt
denn es kann gar nicht anders sein als
ungerecht wenn das publikum das werk
eines künstlers der in mehr als einem
halben jahrhundert fast 2000 gemälde
zeichnungen und grafiken schuf der ein
wegbereiter der kunst des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts war dann am ende in einem
einzigen motiv zusammen rafft so erging
es aber dem norweger edvard munch mit
dem schrei so darf das nicht stehen
bleiben
deshalb kommt der schrei gar nicht erst
vor in der großen werkschau über etwa
die heute im k20 in düsseldorf eröffnet
sie soll mundgerecht werden das ist
absicht des mannes der die schau
zusammengestellt kuratiert hat karl oder
klaus bath
der bekannteste und erfolgreichste
schriftsteller norwegen seinen landsmann
also von mund die zusammenarbeit ist
eine verbeugung vor dem kunst und
literatur land norwegen gastland der
frankfurter buchmesse dieses jahr
dass das norwegische prinzenpaar in
deutschland eine ausstellung eröffnet
kommt selten vor doch wenn es um zwei
stars ihres landes geht kommen sie gern
karl uwe knaus guard trifft auf edward
moore
der schriftsteller hat in der
kunstsammlung nordrhein westfalen eine
ausstellung kuratiert über den maler der
in norwegen so etwas ist wie ein
nationalheiligtum beim sex ein bisschen
in dieser ausstellung hat uns klaus hat
den gefallen getan
viele unbekannte werke von mut zu zeigen
wir sehen eine größere vielfalt in es
ist ein anderer
ein ungewöhnlicher blick auf den
bekannten schrei gibt es nicht zu sehen
dafür 140 selten gezeigte werke kaum
düsternis sondern blumengärten natur
idyllen auch das ist mo klaus guard hat
sich themenräume ausgedacht die man
beschreiten kann ein gang durchs
seelenleben ich wollte vier räume
konzipieren die wie kapitel eines buches
sind sie sollten sehr unterschiedlich
seien unterschiedliche atmosphären haben
es hat unglaublich viel spaß gemacht es
war wie dirigieren
karl uwe knaus card gilt als der
wichtigste norwegische schriftsteller
der gegenwart in seinem land wird er
gefeiert wie ein popstar
seit er seine autobiografie
veröffentlicht hat sechs bände in denen
er schonungslos offen sein leben
beschreibt die bücher ein welterfolg das
schreiben für ihn ein kampf er ist
ständig produktiv etwas was ihn mit buch
verbindet man fühlt sich sehr
verletzlich aber das schreiben ist auch
das gegenteil davon
es ist ein ort an dem man sich
verstecken kann ein ort an dem man
sicher ist und ich nehme an
auch für mich war das malen ein ort wo
er sein konnte wo er sicher war
boock war hoch sensibel verschlossen ein
einzelgänger erlitt am leben der tod
begleitete ihn enge familienmitglieder
starben früh in seiner kunst konnte er
sich befreien
auf der leinwand offenbarte er allen
seine seele in seiner kompromisslosen
offenheit war er radikal genau wie karl
uwe knaus gar als privatperson waren
nicht immer mutig als künstler schon das
sollte einem immer wieder eine
erinnerung sein dass man auch so wird
vielleicht nicht sehr mutig aber doch
ein bisschen
man muss ständig die dinge die man weiß
hinterfragen und er tat das permanent
malen im hier und jetzt wahrhaftig sein
klaus guard zeigt uns einen stetig
zweifelnden einen der ihm ein bisschen
ähnelt
es ist ein spannender und neuer blick
auf norwegens künstlers dar
immer erwähnt ich ein wenig zweifeln das
passt ja bekommen gerade aus saarbrücken
die nachricht dass sich die junge union
die jugend der cdu vorgenommen hat dass
die nächste kanzler kanzlerkandidatur in
einer abstimmung unter den mitgliedern
festgelegt wird das will die vorsitzende
annegret kramp karrenbauer nicht das
heißt also nicht dass das passieren wird
das heißt nur dass die vorsitzende jetzt
ein problem mehr hat wenn sie zum
beispiel am sonntag vor den jungen
leuten spricht mit dieser aktuellen
nachrichten entlassen wir sie in das
reich von spott und satire auch dort
gibt es ja eine art nachrichtensendung
aber das wissen sie schon bismarck und
ein gutes noch
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend sie haben es
bestimmt auch schon gemerkt es wird so
langsam herbstlicher die blätter färben
sich bunt aber die temperatur und jetzt
am wochenende erinnern doch eher an
sommer in freiburg zum beispiel sind am
sonntag und am montag über 25 grad
möglich und selbst im norden wie hier in
hamburg erreichen wir am sonntag dann um
die 20 grad aber lange hätte das ganze
nicht an spätestens am dienstag sinken
dann die höchstwerte doch wieder unter
20 grad wir schauen in die tiefste werte
der kommenden nacht da haben wir im
süden vier bis zehn grad bei aufklaren
südbayern 2 im norden bleibt es bei 12
bis 14 grad
das ist doch ein deutlicher kontrast der
mit der wolken verteilung zu tun hat wie
heute schon den ganzen tag sind die
nehmen dich im norden dich dabei anfangs
kräftigem regen und teils stürmischem
wind richtung süden ist es dann doch
teils sternenklar
genau diese grenze wird morgen vormittag
noch etwas schärfer nördlich einer linie
münsterland nordbrandenburg ist es grau
und nass wieder aber insgesamt gibt es
schon weniger wind und weniger regen als
heute südlich davon streit dann wieder
die sonne
allerdings wird es nachmittags im
südwesten interessant da kommen von
frankreich her nämlich ein paar
quellwolken wahrscheinlich bleibt aber
bei einzelnen schauern
dazu haben wir 14 bis 19 grad unter den
wolken 22 bis 25 grad sind dann schon
bei sonne und wie gesagt am sonntag 26
27 grad vom oberen über franken bis zur
saale ein bisschen sonne auch im norden
aber im nordwesten sind immer noch
schauer und gewitter möglich und in der
neuen woche dann von westen her schon
wieder wechselhafter tschüss